mesdames messieurs les élus sert marine
cher stéphane mesdames messieurs chers
amis à ceux qui viennent d'arriver au
touquet et je leur souhaite la bienvenue
et à ceux qui sont là avec nous depuis
ce matin je les remercie bien évidemment
de leur écoute amical et j'en suis sûr
attentive je vais vous faire une
confidence être élu local à 27 ans mère
d'une ville de 11000 habitants et
conseiller départemental du plus beau
département de france le pas de calais
n'est pas vous vous en doutez une
sinécure ce n'est pas à la charge de
travail les appels au milieu de la nuit
où les incivilités qui me marque le plus
non ce qui me marque le plus jeune élu
local
c'est l'état de désespérance voire même
d'inquiétude profonde dans lesquels les
français sont plongés aujourd'hui en
réalité mes concitoyens que je croise
chaque jour me font part plus encore que
de leurs inquiétudes de leur
incompréhension leur incompréhension
face à l'inaction du gouvernement
empêtré dans une inaptitude chronique à
gérer les affaires du pays
leur incompréhension face à l'absence de
résultats face à la novlangue socialiste
nous expliquant qu'une hausse moins
forte du chômage serait en réalité une
baisse de celui ci face à l'explosion du
nombre de tués sur les routes
face à l'instabilité fiscale faisant
peser l'effort sur les classes moyennes
ceux qui sont toujours trop riche pour
recevoir des aides mais toujours trop
pauvre pour épargner et préparer le
futur de leurs enfants ils sont
également inquiet face à l'insécurité
galopante
face à la hausse vertigineuse de la
dette face à la croissance zéro qui
serait une bonne nouvelle
face au laxisme intolérable de la
justice de christiane taubira et face
aux mesures anti éducative de najat
vallaud belkacem
mais les français manifestent également
leur incompréhension face à l'état de la
france
subissant la politique européenne
au lieu d'en être à l'initiative ces
français qui constate jour après jour
l'absence de réponse à la problématique
migratoire maire de la deuxième ville du
calaisis mais habitants subissent de
plein fouet cette inaction
gouvernementale
et quel contraste avec l'action des
républicains sur ce sujet du courage
sans faille du maire de calais natacha
bouchart abandonnés par l'état
socialiste faisant de la gesticulation
leur seul élément de réponse et c'est
républicain également qui font des
propositions audacieuses par la voix du
président de notre mouvement
nicolas sarkozy qui est le seul
représentant des propositions crédibles
permettant la fois de restaurer le
prestige de notre pays tout en trouvant
une solution au problème
ce problème migratoire
ce n'est pas en érigeant des murs en
fermant les frontières ou alors
dernières nouvelles en donne en mille
euros au maire qui héberge une famille
que nous allons le résoudre mais c'est
en travaillant sur deux axes forts
tout d'abord en prenant le problème à la
racine dans les pays d'émigration puis
en harmonisant les politiques
migratoires et pour reprendre une
formule du maire de calais entre
humanité et fermeté dans tous les pays
de l'union européenne
vous le voyez mes chers amis le
sentiment des français
vu à travers les yeux d'un jeune élu
local est clair il faut redonner à la
france et à ses habitants la confiance
dans le futur et le retour de cette
confiance ne peut passer dans notre
région nord pas de calais picardie que
par la victoire du courage de xavier
bertrand et en 2017 que par celle de
notre mouvement et de nos idées mené par
un homme d'état sans équivalent par son
dynamisme sa volonté à toute épreuve et
son charisme notre président nicolas
sarkozy je vous remercie